et voilà c'est ma vie non je crois qu'il
était temps de mettre de l'ordre dans
ton nez s'allonge ah oui il y à vraiment
trop d'objets sur leurs gardes
une petite cuillère un ballon en
caoutchouc amy se met alors à cazouls
tennis celle où veux tu me fais rire je
vais tout faire tomber excuse moi car
vous êtes là et j'étais tellement
occupés et des sabrina que je vous avais
pas vus qu'est ce qui se passe quasiment
j'ai perdu une de mes marc agrafes ou
bien par bus une quoi une sa peau
casimir casimir les enfants ils ont
emmené voir
mettez-vous là inès vas tu mettras côté
pacers
voilà regardez-moi marathon qu'est ce
que c'est que ça une baraque à skis a
répondu c'est al sait très bien qu est
ce qu il ya dans une maracas un débit
pour faire de la musique
et qu'est ce que c'est qu'une maracas
effet pourquoi un pour faire du bruit
pour faire de la musique et de quel pays
ça vient françoise et jean luc nous
françoise de écoute moi où tu laisses et
casimir sait de quel pays ça vient ça de
belgique jeudi de tahiti a je crois
qu'ils en haïti mais ça vient surtout
d'amérique et d'amérique du sud est
[Musique]
est ce que l'un d'entre vous les
bouteilles est ce que l'un d'entre vous
a vu la deuxième maraka de casimir je
vais perdu s'il en faut deux pour jouer
à la belote celui de caisse qui se
pensent j'étais trop chargé j'ai tout
fait tomber sabrina tu n'aurais pas
ramassé mme amara grave erreur et il me
semble que je les ai entendu tomber
attends je vais voir je vois une balle
d'une raquette une clochette une
cuillère quand je n'y vois pas grand
chose
écoute bien
[Musique]
c'est vrai écoutez bien ce que je vais
encore faire tomber qu'est ce que c'est
on écoute l'accueillir c'est ça c'est ça
une grille exact est pas une cloche une
cachette en cachette oui vous trouvez
vite
écoutez un celui-là nom target
oui c'était inversé et celui ci une
boîte non hein parce que c'est non c'est
pas une autre pièce où ben alaoui
castrale sales gosses mais celui là non
trouvez pas non des clés avec les
écouter encore
non non non ça c'est bien fait oui oui
oui bon c'est cet amour ça tient
merci bon moi je suis vraiment bien
content je vous attendais il ya plein de
petits cailloux à l'intérieur alors
venez avec moi qui va nous aider à faire
de miracles à oui voilà amelio gazinière
joue très bien les harragas oui non mais
ce n'est pas ça du tout maintenant ce
sont des maracas
oui alors ce n'est pas seulement pour
faire de la musique
dès lors c'est sur un court regarde
c'est la meilleure façon de se gratter
le haut delépine dorsale comme ça c'est
bon ça fait du bien à ses formidables et